[Music]
[Applause]
george floyd's name
has reverberated around the world but at
the center of this story
is a family in church with supporters
ahead of the trial
one way or another we're gonna get this
justice
their relative but a case for justice
shared by
millions who feel the floyd family is
standing for them
we're thankful to all the protesters all
the activists
everybody in america everybody around
the world who said
until we get justice for george floyd
none of us can breathe
prayerfully at the end of this trial we
can all exhale together
for george floyd give him the breath
that was denied to him by derrick
sheldon
a backdrop of heavy security sets the
stage for the trial at the courthouse in
minneapolis
a small group of activists making their
voices heard
peaceful and undeterred we want to walk
away from this villain like
we won we want our work to pay off
and we want a guilty verdict for all
four officers that is what we want that
is why we're out here
the jury's job now begins hearing
opening statements
the prosecution will make its case first
and it's expected
will argue derek chovin's actions in
keeping his knee on george floyd's neck
for nearly nine minutes
were a direct cause of his death the
defense will seek to cast doubt on those
claims and introduce
evidence to suggest he could have died
from other factors
and that derek shovin didn't intend to
harm him
for many this trial will be a defining
moment for race relations in america
the outcome uncertain and the stakes
high
sally lockwood sky news minneapolis